we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors nebia is a revolutionary shower
head that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman steadymd lets you maintain a
meaningful long lasting relationship
with a primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only ninety nine dollars a month
with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
so uh president-elect joe biden is
starting to fill out his cabinet and we
learned
just in the last few hours really that
joe biden's secretary of state
is going to be anthony blinken and you
are going to notice as i tell you about
anthony blinken
that this is going to be very very
different than donald trump's approach
donald trump's two secretaries of state
were
an oil executive and a right-wing nut
congressman rex tillerson and mike
pompeo respectively
as secretaries of state joe biden is
going to have
a former deputy secretary of state who
started his career at the state
department
under the clinton administration has
huge foreign policy experience and quite
frankly
is what you need temperamentally when
you want to
sort of calm the panic of our foreign
allies
after four years of a child in the white
house with their sycophants
following them around until they are no
longer sycophants rex tillerson of
course being an example of that
now this doesn't mean we're going to
agree with uh um every cabinet pick
that joe biden makes on policy and we're
going to talk about that in a little bit
but we're we are starting to actually
select experienced adults here and
that's a good sign
we've also learned of two more choices
for joe biden uh they are jake sullivan
for national security advisor sullivan
was joe biden's
national security adviser as vp and also
worked under
hillary clinton when she was secretary
of state and then lastly from what we
know so far
we heard about ronald klein a couple of
weeks ago as chief of staff
the the last choice i have to tell you
about today is that linda thomas
greenfield is going to be
joe biden's ambassador to the united
nations again
all important positions for rebuilding
relationships with allies
she is a 35-year foreign service veteran
and biden importantly is going to put
ambassador to the un back on the
national security council this might not
seem huge this is one of those things
that goes
sort of to the character of how a
president approaches
international organizations like the un
part of donald trump's attacks on the
united nation included downgrading the
ambassador to the u.n
so that they were no longer on the nsc
joe biden
is going to put the ambassador to the un
back on the national security council so
a few thoughts so far on this
i'm seeing posts going around uh about
for example oh my god anthony blinken
is against bds the movement to boycott
israel
how dare joe biden well joe biden is
against bds
who would expect that joe biden would
pick a secretary of state
in favor of bds if they themselves
are against bds that's kind of a strange
reaction to have
now uh biden blinken rather
is jewish and i hope that oh my god he's
against bds
is not merely code for oh my god he's
jewish
i'll give the benefit of the doubt on
that blinken did support the iran deal
there are going to be some in israel who
don't like that
i think the iran deal was good anthony
blinken supported the iran deal
i was in favor of the iran deal and i
think that that's a good
thing now secondly this now starts to
give us a sense
of what the biden foreign policy will
likely be
with regard to foreign superpowers
as well as different regions of the
world we're starting to see based on
these selections of anthony blinken
as well as jake sullivan etc this
probably means more time
effort and resources are going to go
into the relationship with india as an
example
this probably means more time in africa
where
china has spent significant time and
resources
getting more involved with tech and
infrastructure
over the last many years these are the
type i mean it feels weird to even be
talking with you guys in these terms
today because we're starting to get back
to policy
we're starting to get back to
geopolitics foreign policy
relationships between countries it it's
like we this has been so sorely needed
for a long time
uh blink and likely will also have as a
priority to spend more time
trying to bolster guatemala honduras el
salvador and latin america
in what ways we don't yet know and then
of course if it's russia china africa
and latin america
what's missing from that is middle east
and there may not be i mean
this may not be an administration uh and
a state department
that is going to focus as much on the
middle east
as the recent three administrations have
that doesn't necessarily
uh that's not necessarily a bad thing
and of course the devil
is is in the details um trump one
interesting note is
donald trump never extended an arm
controls deal
with russia and as a result of that the
incoming biden administration is going
to have about two weeks after
inauguration
to extend that with russia if indeed it
is going to be extended that's a big
thing and that's going to set the tone
for a lot of the relate the three-way
relationship
between the us russia and china and
that's going to be in the first couple
of weeks of the biden administration so
that's something to look at
now there's plenty of sort of good here
a return to normalcy
adults at the table qualified people at
the table
what's the bad uh anthony blinken is no
progressive that's that's the reality
and uh anthony blinken is more
interventionist
than i am although joe biden has not
shown
an interest during the campaign in
campaigning on
interventionist priorities we know that
blinken is
more of an interventionist than joe
biden ran
on and this is something that i'm not on
board with generally as a rule of thumb
if you look at some of blankens past
comments about iraq
seeming to be more in the mindset of the
problem was how it was done
rather than the fact that it was done at
all and
that's something that i disagree with
and this is the way that
uh we are going to get back into
shifting to
okay great we've got adults back in
charge this is a highly qualified choice
and that's a good thing
but now we actually have to keep them
accountable about what they do now one
one other thing
there was a hilarious reaction from a
lot of people
on the right about biden's choosing
a no-name who the hell has ever heard of
anthony blinken
this is one of those things we're going
to have to become reaccustomed to
after the trump administration donald
trump regularly picked people
because he saw them on fox news or saw
them on tv
it's okay to have people in positions of
power
that are not regulars on cable news and
that may not be household names
that's fine and in fact in some cases it
can be better
and i think that it's a good thing that
joe biden is already going in that
direction
we've gotten very lucky or maybe better
said we are very fortunate that as soon
as december 11th or 12th
we are expecting that people will start
to be vaccinated with one of two
coronavirus vaccines
that are believed to be 95 efficacious
in preventing coronavirus now with flu
vaccines and other vaccines
we very often don't have near 95 percent
uh effective vaccines and we are on the
path to having multiple such vaccines
for coronavirus
the astrazeneca oxford vaccine also
announcing today
that their data shows it is a 90
effective vaccine so we are
on the way to very soon having two
vaccines going in the u.s
there's this third vaccine which has a
slightly different timeline that should
be available relatively soon
and yet herd immunity is still going to
be in jeopardy because of existing
anti-vaccine sentiment which could
absolutely
explode once the vaccine is available so
there's good news and there's bad news
here let's go over everything we know
pfizer and moderna each have coronavirus
vaccines
said to be 95 effective
huge based on phase three clinical
trials now the fda
and independent review groups are going
to be meeting for three days december 8
9 and 10
to decide about reviewing the data and
potentially granting an emergency use
authorization on one or both of these
vaccines
if they do that on december 10th you
could see people being vaccinated
on december 11th or december 12th we
desperately need vaccines
the virus is out of control we had a
24-hour period
this weekend with 200 000 new cases
we have had 1600 to 2000 people dying
per day
once again in the us of the virus and
yet
according to the latest gallup poll 42
percent of americans
say they would not get the vaccine
if there was an fda approved vaccine
today
that's really bad because if not enough
people
get this vaccine we are not going to get
to hurt immunity and dr
anthony fauci talked about this over the
weekend when he appeared on cbs's face
the nation let's listen to him explain
it
to the hope the scientific advisor to
operation warp speed said this morning
we could have
true herd immunity take place
somewhere in the month of may as the
vaccine is distributed
does america go back to life as normal
in may
uh you know i don't think so uh unless
we do and i believe you're referring to
monsef salawi you said that and i
totally
agree with him but there are there are a
couple of things that go into the
effectiveness
of a vaccine program a highly
efficacious vaccine
and we're there we have two of them that
have a 95 percent
efficacy the other part of the equation
is how many people get vaccinated
so if you have a highly efficacious
vaccine
and only a relatively small 40-50
percent of the people get vaccinated
you're not going to get the herd
immunity you need what we do need
is we need to get as many people as
possible
vaccinated and that's why we want to be
very transparent for people
to understand the independent and
transparent process
that got us to the point of saying which
the fda will examine it very carefully
now
together with advisory committees that
are completely independent and declare
with an eua and ultimately a license
that the vaccines are safe and effective
when the american public hears that you
should be assured
that that is the case and if you get an
overwhelming majority of the people
vaccinated with a highly efficacious
vaccine
we can reasonably quickly get to the
hurt immunity that would be a blanket of
protection
for the country so of course he's right
and people saying that this vaccine was
rushed
it wasn't rushed this is a type of
vaccine based on an
mrna platform that just takes less time
to develop than traditional vaccines the
traditional
coronavirus vaccines are also being
developed we're expecting them in the
second half
of 2021. this was not rushed and
anti-vaxxers are going to be going
absolutely crazy
as these vaccines roll out and add to
that
people who just don't think coronavirus
is serious enough
to warrant getting a vaccine why well
because donald trump has been
downplaying it for a long time
now of course there will be anti-vaxxers
fear-mongering about
mandatory vaccines there is not going to
be a mandatory coronavirus vaccine
what you will be seeing and we're
already starting to seeing it
starting to see it is that many sports
venues
concert venues hopefully even airlines
we've heard from qantas which said they
will be doing this
public schools maybe who will say after
a certain date
you need proof of vaccination to attend
come to a concert
go to school here fly on our airline you
don't have to get a vaccine
but if you want to choose to come to a
sports game here
or fly on our airline you will have to
have a vaccine
ticketmaster already announcing they are
rolling out the infrastructure to be
able to do that
qantas so far the first airline i'm
aware of that announced that
that is something they're planning to do
i'm hopeful
that that will encourage sort of like as
a carrot rather than a stick
more vaccination and of course the
difference between
you having a vaccine that's 95 effective
versus everyone having it is huge if you
have the vaccine
and nobody else does and it's 95
effective it means that
one out of 20 times that you interact
with someone with the virus
in a situation where you could get the
virus one out of 20
you will get the virus if you go back to
normal work
indoors without masks and interact with
a lot of people
you can quickly understand how a 1 in 20
shot at getting the virus
even when vaccinated still leaves you
quite vulnerable
if everybody has a five percent chance
of getting it from
everyone they interact to by definition
you are talking about herd immunity and
that is a very very different thing
the only upside my last thought on this
the only upside to 40
of the country not wanting a vaccine is
that it means
a vaccine may be available for those who
do
want them sooner in other words me
as someone who is not high priority on
the vaccine list
if everybody wants a vaccine i might not
be able to get one until i don't know
may june even if only 60 percent of the
country want vaccines
it's plausible i could end up with a
vaccine in february or march
although overall society will be less
protected
that's the only upside i can see for the
people like me who are waiting for a
vaccine
let me know what you think we will have
more on vaccines
later this week and of course you can
find me on twitter
deepakman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different
experience than any other shower head
i've used i can get in and out of the
shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed
that it's only using about half as much
water
nebia also offers a number of shower
accessories like shelves and curtains
which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use the code pacman will get
15 off site-wide
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that our program is mostly
funded by individual memberships one of
which you can grab it
join pacman.com the new coupon code
is fresh start i don't think i have to
explain to you why that's the new coupon
code use it to get a
70 percent discount from your choice of
membership
at joinpacman.com so donald trump has
now gone about a month without taking
questions from reporters he's been
almost completely missing from the
public eye
and last friday he finally did a
so-called press conference now i say so
called because
he could have really pre-recorded it and
just played a video he took no questions
there was no interaction whatsoever with
the press that was actually
in the room the event was supposed to be
about his work on prescription drug
prices
and trump somehow managed to hold it
together for the first few minutes
and then he just couldn't and you can
see him trying to resist but in the
middle of reading from his notes
about prescription drugs he goes off
scripts
and he blurts out that he actually won
the election now as a reminder he didn't
win the election he lost by
quite a bit the entire event goes
completely off the rails from there
let's look at it here is donald trump
mid-sentence about big pharma running
ads against him and he just loses it and
blurts out that he won
this is not an easy thing to do big
pharma ran
millions of dollars of negative
advertisements against me during the
campaign which i won by the way but you
know we'll find that out
almost 74 million votes we had big
pharma against us we had
the media against us we had big tech
against us
we had a lot of dishonesty against us
but big pharma alone ran millions and
millions of dollars in ads in fact i
looked at it and said who is it
they uh i won by the way i had
dishonesty against me it's
truly embarrassing at this point it's
actually been embarrassing a really long
time
he just cannot control himself i won
guys
i won really i did believe me it's
it's to some degree like he's trying to
convince himself
that he won a few other strange moments
here is donald trump
saying he's been loyal to special
interests
i don't know if this is a freudian slip
or if donald trump thinks
it means something different than what
we think it means to say you've been
loyal to special interests
i don't know but take a listen to this
lawyers lobbyists
and bought and paid for politicians
but i've been loyal to the special
interests i've been loyal to our
patients
yeah so it's it's unclear if donald
trump knows
what that means or understands that
typically you don't want to admit
to being all about the special interests
uh loyal to special interests in
politics but
who know it's trump you know it could be
a freudian slip he might not understand
what it means
he might be honest he might be glad
about being loyal to special interests i
don't know
trump then also just can't get away
from the me me me saying we are
only this close to vaccines because of
him
and in saying this he instead of saying
pfizer
the pharmaceutical company he says fisa
which is something else altogether the
foreign intelligence surveillance act
it's just a mess i was put here to do a
job
and fisa and others
were way ahead on vaccines you wouldn't
have a vaccine if it weren't for me for
another four years because fda would
have never been able to do what they did
now in fact the fda hasn't really done
anything yet on vaccines i hope people
understand this
private companies and universities have
been developing vaccines
the fda in a couple of weeks is going to
meet
along with some independent panels and
they will look
at the data from these companies pfizer
bio entec moderna oxford astrazeneca is
moving ahead very quickly and they will
decide
in december whether these vaccines
should get emergency use as we've
already discussed so
this is weird and it's even getting
stranger and stranger
as it goes on donald trump remaining
very conspiratorial
suggesting that news of a coronavirus
vaccine receiving approval
after the election was part of the
conspiracy to bring him down
that they could have announced this
before the election but it might have
helped him they didn't want to help him
so they waited take a look
their vaccine in other words not come
out with a vaccine
until just after the election that's
because of what i did with favored
nations and these other
elements instead of their original plan
to assess the data in october so they
were going to come out in october
but they decided to delay it because of
what i'm doing which is fine with me
because frankly
this is just a very big thing a very big
thing what i'm doing here i don't know
if anyone's going to appreciate it these
people can't even believe it
alex even you can't believe it can you
look at you
so they waited and waited and waited and
they thought they'd come out with it a
few days after the election
yeah and it would have probably had an
impact who knows maybe it wouldn't have
so donald trump of course as always
the ultimate victim complaining that he
doesn't get appreciation
no one has been treated less fairly than
donald trump in the world in the history
of the world of any president in history
if you believe his perspective and he
almost
kind of back candidly admits that he
lost saying
if the vaccine had been approved before
the election
i might have won but of course he's also
trying to convince us that he did win
so he has to back up and say well maybe
it would maybe it wouldn't have had
an impact and then lastly as uh
seema verma wraps up she's just horrible
she's been a part of donald trump's
coronavirus task force for a while
uh after seema verma wraps up donald
trump just kind of slowly slinking off
after waving to someone in the audience
without even saying
the press briefing is over on a
microphone naturally not taking
a single question success over the last
four years is a testimony
to that mentality thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the election was three weeks ago joe
biden has selected
a uh treasury secretary who he says he
will tell us sometime around
thanksgiving he selected a chief of
staff
he's selected a secretary of state a
national security adviser
an ambassador to the united nations joe
biden has created and has started
meeting with a coronavirus task force
and he's been speaking to governors
about what are we going to do
in terms of masks in terms of the virus
in terms of all of this
and meanwhile donald trump and his
administration
still have not even acknowledged hey we
had an election
you aren't going to be president anymore
in eight and a half weeks they still
have not acknowledged that
truly bizarre times that we are living
through uh i am very much looking
forward to as i said earlier
in our discussion about foreign policy
and uh
um donald trump joe biden rather uh
choosing his secretary of state
i really am looking forward to getting
back to
more substantive policy discussion once
we can get rid of this menace and
we are eight and a half weeks from it so
rudy giuliani
is not the only whacked-out lawyer
representing
donald trump in his futile attempts to
overturn the results of the 2020
election
which joe biden won there's this other
lawyer
named sidney powell now last week when i
noted
sidney powell seems absolutely out of
her mind
during that bizarre press conference at
which rudy giuliani's face
melted some people wrote to me and said
david you know it
kind of sounds like you're making fun of
sydney powell's accent
i guess she's southern that's not what
it was
with any accent the things sydney powell
was saying make no sense she suggested
last week
that there was a conspiracy to steal the
election from donald trump by joe biden
involving this is not a joke venezuela
and cuba
the long dead hugo chavez and nicolas
maduro
george soros antifa some guy named eric
coomer and the clinton foundation she
seemed
completely out of her mind we now have
more video evidence that she is indeed
very sick she was interviewed on newsmax
tv over the weekend newsmax is this
even crazier alternative to fox news
that donald trump has been recommending
along with oan
and she claimed that they will be making
a
biblical filing about voter fraud
against donald trump she says the the
filings are coming
and they will be biblical what does that
mean i have no idea see if you can
figure it out
you know i know you say you want to do
your arguing in court you are an
attorney you're not a press secretary
but you all did have a press conference
last week
jordan sekulow said that there's going
to be a filing soon in georgia that
would be explosive
can you tell us anything can you make
some news with us here tonight tell us
anything new that you're going to
present
in that filing in georgia
well i'm i i can't say that yet
but hopefully this week we will we will
get it ready to
file sydney what's in it it will it will
be biblical
biblical guys we we have to be allowed
to call this what it is these are
delusions
this is mental illness we can't say well
because she's a christian this is not
mental illness
a biblical filing about fraud
in a court of law guys please this is
where
you know if this were not trump's lawyer
and this were not a christian
if they said something equivalent to
this you would be looking at a 72-hour
cycle for an individual like this she
also said that there are likely
thousands of people involved in the
conspiracy
i mean how big of a you know if if this
happened how big of a conspiracy how
many people would have had to have been
in on something like this
oh gosh uh probably thousands including
the
people running the machines at each of
the polls
polling centers we know for example that
one of the higher ups of dominion went
to detroit
the night of the election to to handle
things himself
and we also have evidence that there
were any number of
vpn lines open to the internet for
foreign actors to be meddling in it yeah
thousands of people in on it one of the
things we know from experience
is that when there are more than a
handful of people involved
you can't cover it up and yet we had the
texas governor offering a million
dollars
as a reward for proof of voter fraud
nobody's been able to collect the
million dollars
their sworn affidavits keep getting
dismissed in court
courts keep finding there's no merit to
any of these claims
if thousands of people are involved
there would be widespread
undeniable proof you can't cover it up
if thousands of people are involved
and then sydney powell goes back into
the stuff about venezuela venezuelan
witnesses
has anybody given you an explanation
that that as to why they had to turn the
machines off
you talk about how the machines got
turned off
our key our witness from venezuela who
saw it all created and how it worked
said that he knew as soon as the
machines were turned off in those key
states it was because we the people
in voting trump and voting for trump in
a landslide election had essentially
broken the algorithm that had been
pre-programmed into the machine so they
had to stop
counting in those states did you hear
that one
people voted for trump so overwhelmingly
that it broke the machine algorithms
whatever that means she says trump lost
by six million
and she's saying trump won by so much
that it broke the machines this
is a very sick person and sadly people
fall for it
and it has even become too much for the
trump campaign they put out a statement
yesterday after this interview came out
saying that sydney powell is practicing
law on her own
she's not part of donald trump's legal
team she's not a trump lawyer
she's essentially been fired because up
until yesterday
she did appear to be all of those things
donald trump even previously tweeted
about her
that he has the best lawyers and
representatives including sydney powell
which we have up on the screen for you
it's just a hilarious comedy of errors
the trump campaign now distancing from
this lunatic woman as quickly as they
can
but people fall for it i got a very
distressing email over the weekend from
a viewer
who said david my mom completely fell
for that press conference
the press conference you and i likely
watched and we see rudy giuliani's hair
dye melting
and sydney powell blaming antifa and
george soros and and
venezuela for stealing the election and
we recognize these are ill people
this viewer's mom fell for it and
thought that sydney powell is just a
brilliant lawyer
doing god's work and this viewer spent
hours
convincing his mom that that's not the
case
it's really scary stuff and as with
trumpism
in general the really scary part is the
number of people
just falling for this nonsense hook line
and sinker
biblical submissions proving
voter fraud against donald trump sad
and scary we'll have more about this on
our instagram page
we are at davidpakmanshow on instagram
while you're there you can follow me on
instagram as well
at david.pack the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me
and my medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video
welcome back to the david pakman show so
we finally got an actual press briefing
from uh donald trump's press secretary
kaylee mcinanny on friday
and she is apparently just determined to
humiliate herself as many times as
possible
in the uh eight and a half weeks that
remain before donald trump leaves office
she took
very few questions lied uncontrollably
and called a reporter an activist before
walking off
uh the podium every aspect of the
public-facing communications from this
administration have been
debasing the office of the presidency in
embarrassing and shameful ways and i'm
talking about trump's tweets
trump's press briefings his press
secretary's press briefings his cabinet
members like mike pompeo insisting there
will be
a transition to a second trump
administration even
though joe biden won it's been pathetic
and it's been globally embarrassing
and kaylee apparently not doing what
donald trump has been doing which is
mostly hiding from public eye
she continues to go on tv and now hold a
press briefing
hugely embarrassing herself so let's
start with a huge
whopper from kaylee mcinanni claiming
that listen uh trump giving joe biden
a peaceful transition isn't the issue
trump was never given a peaceful
transition by obama
or hillary i guess she means imagine
that
and then listen to this something that i
would note is
just we talked a lot about transfer of
power and the election and it's worth
remembering
um that this president was never given
an orderly transition of power
his presidency was never accepted in
fact before
the election his election we know
crossfire hurricane was launched by
peter strzok to pursue a baseless
allegations about
the president's ties with russia that's
before he was president trying to
subvert
the will of the american people we know
in august peter strzok wrote a text
message about
an insurance policy against a trump
presidency once again trying to silence
the voice of the american people
um in 2016 we know in october that there
was a fisa warrant
a fisa warrant taken out to spy on the
trump campaign
then the american people spoke and they
spoke commandingly in electing president
trump despite
all of the odds it's hard to imagine a
more dishonest claim
about how the 2016 transition went it's
almost like they don't recognize that
there's video of stuff
hillary clinton conceded the election
and called donald trump to congratulate
him
within hours of it being called barack
obama
invited donald trump to the white house
the day after
the election shook hands with him had
him in the oval office
and said i want him to do well if he
does well the country does well
barack obama went to donald trump's
inauguration and
shook hands with trump and then
gracefully flew off
in air force one this is just a pathetic
lie and they don't even know what to lie
about anymore
kaylee mcinanni made no mention of the
fact that
trump lost they still don't acknowledge
losing here is reporter brian karam
trying to question kaylee uh about this
and she just calls on somebody else
when will you in this election kaylee at
one point
the entire event completely farcical
here kaylee mcinanni smears caitlyn
collins as an activist
as she walks away after taking just a
few questions
in 2016 and four years into his
presidency
thank you everyone for the very good and
substantive
i'm not an activist and you haven't
taken questions since october 1st and
you just took
about five haley that's not doing your
job
your taxpayer-funded job it's actually
hilarious
that kaylee says she won't take
questions
from kay uh from caitlin collins because
she's from cnn and she's an activist
and yet chanel ryan from oan
gets to ask these conspiracy black hole
questions
and kaylee says oh chanel
is a journalist but caitlyn is an
activist i mean we're living in bizarro
world here
quite frankly caitlyn collins from cnn
actually summarizing it perfectly in a
tweet
where she said after the press briefing
it's understandable why someone who
hasn't done
their job taking questions from
reporters in weeks
would confuse someone else doing theirs
with activism
this is really all just sad more than
anything and the united states is worse
off for it
we have to move past it we have to start
repairing the country
and this next story is about joe biden
trying to do that at least as he sees it
and donald trump just can't take it
getting very triggered over the weekend
once again
one of the reassuring things that we are
seeing lately
is that no matter what donald trump does
joe biden is
steadily moving forward with a steady
hand he's having meetings
he has his own coronavirus task force
he's choosing cabinet members including
secretary of state who we talked about
earlier anthony blinken
and this is so triggering to donald
trump
it's very clear that donald trump is
trying to pretend this isn't going on
he's golfing all weekend he's otherwise
not leaving the white house
he's uh sort of been sucked into this
world of
his sick offense and yes men but this
really seemed to boil over during the
weekend
as donald trump unleashed a completely
unhinged tweet storm
and this is really the stuff of his
history books we have never seen
a sitting president react this way just
to losing that's all that happened he
just lost it's nothing more it's nothing
less
donald trump tweeting why is joe biden
so
quickly forming a cabinet when my
investigators have found hundreds of
thousands of fraudulent votes
enough to flip at least four states
which in turn is more than enough to win
the election hopefully the courts or
legislatures will have the courage to do
what has to be done
to maintain the integrity of our
elections
and the united states of america itself
the world is watching
joe biden is forming a cabinet because
he won
joe biden's not even doing it
particularly quickly it's that
donald trump is slow to acknowledge that
he lost
there are not enough votes to flip a
single state
that we are aware of at this point in
time never mind four states
the world is laughing at trump and
crying
at the downfall of american democracy in
terms of a sitting president attacking
the democratic process in this way
and the world is also rejoicing that
donald trump will be leaving
trump then continued tweeting quote it's
all about the signatures on the
envelopes why are the democrats fighting
so hard to find them we will find
massive numbers of fraudulent
ballots the signatures won't match fight
hard republicans don't let them destroy
the evidence every single one of these
tweets flagged by twitter as disputed
which you know as i said last week
disputed is like the understatement of
the decade at this point
uh and then trump furious apparently he
thinks he deserves credit for the
upcoming vaccines
and that biden will get the credit trump
saying they never thought a vaccine
could be done so soon but don't worry
they will try to give the credit to
biden now of course
everyone thought that given these mrna
vaccine platforms which are
faster to develop that the vaccine would
be done sometime around end of the year
2020
that it is exactly what it seems like it
will be and that they will start to be
more widely available
in the first quarter of 2021 so
everybody everybody thought that if you
were paying attention
and then just trump attacking joe biden
more tweeting joe biden was a total
disaster and handling
the h1n1 swine flu would never have
produced a vaccine in record time
years ahead of schedule i mean
everything about that is a lie
and would do a terrible job of vaccine
delivery but doesn't everyone already
know that
this went on all weekend in and out of
golfing
trump was tweeting agit trash about joe
biden
it has to end joe biden's forming a
cabinet because that's what the
president-elect
does during the 10 weeks between
election day and inauguration day
courts are dismissing donald trump's
lawsuits because they are without merit
states aren't flipping because biden won
the states
you know that phrase threats foreign and
domestic this unwillingness to accept
the loss
and continued attempts to subvert the
will of the people
this is one of those domestic threats
that we are so often warned about
we have to protect against it and so far
and i know we have to be cautious but
realistic
so far every attempt that they have had
to subvert the will of the people has
not worked
i don't believe it will work and i think
we are just under two months
from the inauguration of uh president
joe biden
full stop if you think the outcome will
be something else
let me know i'm on twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so one of the funniest things that we've
seen since the election is this sort of
dr
jekyll and mr hyde bipolar fox news
that fox news on the one hand has the
people saying
biden won and trump's furious with them
and trump is in fact so furious with
that side of fox news
that he's been tweeting and advocating
for people to go watch newsmax and oan
instead of fox news but at the same time
donald trump still has a lot of friends
at fox news and if you look at the
nighttime opinion programming tucker
carlson
people like lou dobbs i believe over on
fox business during the day maria
bartoromo judge jeanine pirro
certainly sean hannity they're still
saying trump won this thing and joe
biden stole it with fraud so it's just
wacky because it it is very it's bipolar
in nature
um now with all of this it came
to a head in spectacular fashion when
bomb throwing conspiracy host jessie
waters went
up against geraldo rivera in
uh just a ridiculous assessment of the
rudy giuliani meltdown
interview or meltdown press conference
where rudy giuliani's hair dye was
melting and
sydney powell said that there was proof
from venezuela and cuba
and george soros they're all involved in
the conspiracy that crazy press
conference
was so nuts that even trump supporter
geraldo rivera
even friend of trump geraldo rivera had
to say
listen this these are conspiracies this
is over right this is done
and jesse waters didn't like it and it
just falls apart
absolutely brilliantly we'll see what
happens come on jesse
i mean really come on
the clinton foundation george soros hugo
chavez
i'm probably the only person in this
building have actually met yugos
javascript
an international conspiracy why not
elvis you know i didn't mention anything
like
that i'm talking sword after you're a
lawyer you're a
i wanted him to win this election what i
saw with rudy giuliani who i've known
for decades
was bizarre it was unfocused there was
conspiracy theory this and that
you can you when you have a evidence
that you suggest
you what's the lawsuit that that
evidence attaches to what's the action
you you can't go to a court and say did
fraud
judge prove it for me or is the fbi to
prove it for me
should want everybody to be confident in
the results of the election falsehood
if you don't pursue these fraud
allegations half the country is going to
feel like it was crooked
you don't want that and so jesse waters
says if you don't pursue the allegations
the country will believe it was crooked
well
half the country already believes that
and when the fraud allegations get
thrown out they're not going to say
oh the allegations were thrown out i
guess there was no fraud of course not
when courts throw out the fraud
allegations these people instead say
well the courts are part of the
conspiracy
the courts are in on it obviously and uh
this is just like
sydney powell said on the news max
interview i played for you when she says
there are thousands of people involved
in this conspiracy
why not judges as well so jesse
saying in order to make people confident
it wasn't crooked we have to let
this play its way through the courts no
no the courts have become part of the
conspiracy
and trump's defenders keep talking about
you know the existence of sworn
affidavits
simply having sworn affidavits doesn't
prove
anything affidavits are a type of
evidence affidavits are a type of
evidence much like witness testimony
sometimes witness testimony and
affidavits are admissible
sometimes they are not sometimes they
are credible sometimes they are not the
fact that there is
an affidavit or a hundred affidavits or
ten thousand affidavits
it means nothing other than there is a a
witness
willing to say something that's all it
means it might or might not be credible
it might or
may not be hearsay it may or may not be
admissible
having affidavits doesn't mean more than
that and when you start looking into
some of these affidavits that they have
some list they've got lawsuits in
michigan
listing towns from minnesota they have
people signing affidavits who when asked
what happened
can't put together even one coherent
sentence
about what on earth is it you are even
alleging took place here
and then you'll have you know rudy and
others say they signed these affidavits
under penalty of perjury
people testify in court under penalty of
perjury as well
testimony is often disregarded as either
unreliable or biased or dishonest
you rarely see perjury charges perjury
is very hard to prove
you very rarely see it it goes to
proving that someone knowingly lied
versus just misspoke
it's easier to simply call into question
the reliability of what they say and
ignore it if you determine it's not
trustworthy than to go
uh charging people with perjury and it's
the same thing with these sworn
affidavits so
listen geraldo is a total clown he
supported trump
he is trump's friend he wanted trump to
win
so geraldo is not now our go-to
guy he's just sort of like imagine
a group of drunk people at a party
behaving insanely
someone is bound to be the first to
sober up it doesn't mean that they
exercise
good judgment to begin with they're just
the first guy to sober up and say what
the hell happened here
and that's what is going on with geraldo
but he was just as much a part of this
as anybody else
i think you're going to find this clip
interesting republican chris christie
former jersey governor
big trump supporter said over the
weekend
that donald trump's legal challenges
which of course are bogus
that's me saying it not chris have
become a
national embarrassment says chris
christie christie
previously said i think it was very late
on election night
if trump has evidence of fraud uh she he
should be given the opportunity to
present it
christy now says he's been given the
opportunity
he's not presented it and this is now
becoming an embarrassment take a look at
this hours after
president trump's speech on early
wednesday morning the day after the
election
you said it's incumbent on him to come
forward with the evidence there have now
been 34 court cases the president has
lost we saw pennsylvania
last night we saw pat toomey the senator
from pennsylvania say
it's time for the president to enable
this transition it's time for the
president to concede
the president's response was to attack
pat toomey on twitter
is it finally time for this to end
yes and and here's the reason why the
president has had
an opportunity to access the courts and
i said to you you know george starting
at 2 30 a.m on wednesday morning
if you've got the evidence of fraud
presented and what's happened here
is quite frankly the content of the
president's legal team has been
a national embarrassment cindy powell
accusing governor brian kemp
of a crime on television yet being
unwilling to go
on tv and defend and lay out the
evidence that she supposedly has
this is outrageous conduct by any lawyer
and notice george
they won't do it inside the courtroom
they allege fraud outside the courtroom
but when they go inside the courtroom
they don't plead fraud and they don't
argue fraud this is what i was concerned
about at 2 30 in the morning on
wednesday night
listen i've been a supporter of the
presidents i voted for him twice
but elections have consequences and we
cannot
continue to act as if something happened
here
that didn't happen you have an
obligation to present the evidence
the evidence has not been presented and
you must conclude as tucker carlson even
concluded the other night
that if you're unwilling to come forward
and present the evidence it must mean
the evidence doesn't exist
that's what i was concerned about
starting on election night and i remain
concerned today
i think it's wrong i think what you've
heard lots of republicans starting to
say this
i sent it on election night and i hope
more save going forward because
um the country is what has to matter the
most as much as i'm a strong republican
and i love my party it's the country
that has to come first
wow what a powerful message of national
unity and togetherness from chris
christie am i right
no no no i'm wrong i'm i'm that it's not
that at all
they are now dropping like flies simply
to preserve their own political futures
they're not rational or sensible now
they are abandoning the sinking trump
ship before it's too late
if they believed that continuing to push
this was in their interests they would
keep saying it was stolen by joe biden
they care about themselves period they
see the writing on the wall
these are terrible people and this is
now
so absurd that some of them are starting
to bail out chris christie has been one
of the most pathetic
trump brown nosers for the last four
years
and now we're supposed to pretend he's
one of the good guys
give me a break this is just like when
you occasionally hear something
mildly sensible on fox news it's still
fox news
chris christie stood behind donald trump
literally and figuratively
for four years no matter what donald
trump did trump's lack of taking the
virus
seriously is arguably part of how chris
christie himself ended up not only
infected with the virus
but in the hospital for a week or longer
and then he still votes for trump and
his reaction
after the election was hey guys let's
show respect
to the 70 million people that voted for
trump
and now he says oh it's become a
national embarrassment
okay thanks chris he's getting some
distance from trump so that it helps
his political future that's all that
this is
it's fun to watch it is interesting to
the degree
that it triggers donald trump but that's
all
and in fact it's almost ironic to hear
chris christie say
trump's legal team is the national
embarrassment when christie himself has
been a national embarrassment
for a very long time and his path i mean
remember
trump much like trump uh disgustingly
attacked
ted cruz saying his wife is ugly
and went after rand paul and all these
guys
fell in line trump did the same thing to
chris christie
and chris christie ended up there the
day after dropping out of the republican
primary in 2016
standing behind donald trump completely
falling in line
chris christie was part of creating
this national embarrassment and is
complicit in it
and he should have to apologize for that
now
simply saying oh this is starting to be
embarrassing it's too little too late
chris and
if chris christie came out and said guys
i've been complicit in this
i'm sorry the entire presidency was a
disaster i don't know what happened to
me but i throw myself at your mercy
in order to to to be forgiven for what i
did
i would find myself a little more moved
by it if that was the case
this i'm not falling for this this this
is bs and this is the
the rats leaving the sinking ship uh
trying to
trying to preserve their own future
political lives
and it's pathetic and chris christie is
right but it's too little too late we
have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 david p
this is a very important voicemail this
is a voicemail from a
trump supporting cuban american and i
want to take this seriously okay listen
to what this gentleman says
and then we're going to talk about it
hello mr pacman my name is juan i'm a
cuban american
and i voted for trump
the reason i'm calling is
to ask the following question and this
might
help ease the concerns some of us have
what are democrats
doing to ensure or
put out these concerns of this country
steering towards communism or socialism
[Music]
like what unfortunately happened to cuba
and other countries if
democrats are able to
[Music]
show some type of effort
or talk about
ways that they are trying to prevent
that from happening maybe that will
uh help gain more votes from those
concerned like i am
so this is really important because the
framing of the question is completely
wrong
okay this gentleman says i'm a
cuban-american and i voted for trump and
on my spanish language show we've been
talking a lot about this
what what exactly is going on what could
be done
to for democrats to better appeal to
cuban-american voters who often
reflexively out of anti-castro bias are
quick to fall for claims
that any old democrat is a socialist or
a communist when they are not the
question is the wrong one because the
question is
what what what have democrats done what
can democrats do to convince us
that they are not really going to become
make the country socialist or communist
joe biden is not a socialist or a
communist
joe biden has not proposed a single
communist or socialist policy
there are no actual socialists or
communists
in positions of power in the democratic
party in the united states
aoc has called herself a democratic
socialist and so has bernie
and they are not not only are they a
small sliver of the democratic party
they really are social democrats they're
not advocating
uh for the socialization of the means of
production they are
certainly not communist so the problem
is not
that joe biden hasn't yet convinced us
enough that he's not a socialist
there's no evidence there's no policy
there's no reason to think the current
democratic party
has any interest in making the united
states a socialist country the problem
is
too many people have been brainwashed to
think that that's the case
absent any evidence whatsoever and so
we need to deal with this at a systemic
level
is it possible that if we better
understood
socialism and communism people wouldn't
fall for
barack obama as a socialist joe biden's
a socialist is part of it an education
thing
uh it is part of it irresponsible
republican campaigns that if you tell a
lie enough times it starts to become the
truth
i don't know the answer but when you
hear that the question is so wrong
what what what should democrats do to
convince us they're not socialists
what have they done to make you think
they are not a single
sexual socialist policy it's stunning
and it's sad and listen
i am not a socialist i am not a
communist i have never
been in favor of the cuban nor
venezuelan regimes
try out of my own self-interest i would
be telling you
if joe biden was trying to turn the
united states
into a cuban or venezuelan socialist
situation because i would be against
that
i wouldn't vote for that so uh
out of my own views i would be coming to
you and saying guys
there's a risk of socialism here there
is no such risk
and that's where this has gone wrong and
you end up with folks saying
i don't know that biden has done enough
to uh
show me that he's not a socialist has he
done anything to suggest he is
and the answer is of course no we have a
great bonus show for you today we're
going to talk about another retail chain
filing for bankruptcy
we're going to talk about a very
interesting first amendment ruling
involving voice of america
and you are not going to believe what is
going on
with the my pillow guy and
the kenosha shooter kyle rittenhouse
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors nebia
is a revolutionary shower head that
saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
steadymd lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman